on a pas on se rend pas compte mais on
commet des petits forfaits qui sont
quand même qu'ils sont assez à ces
affreux écouté hier soir je suis entré
dans une auberge pour y dîner alors sur
la carte il marque et poussins rôti j'ai
commandé un poussin rôti et j'ai vu
arriver un petit poucet scène j'ai vu un
petit parfum c'est mignon à croquer
ce qu'ils voudront comme ça ça fait
cuire effet pas cuit
et les manger dans l'ombre aux groupes
avaient été lus et où l'eau est dur à
cuire
elle a vécu elle a fait son temps mais
petit poucet en était partie le cas ça
va lui faire cuire un oeuf
ça vaut guère mieux parce que chaque
fois qu'on va se faire cuire un homme
c'est comme si on envoyait un peu ce un
circuit rats et qu'est ce qui fait de
vous un sell-off on est prêt si on
aimerait bien nourris bien sûr parce
qu'il ya quand même ce dilemme se dit
même que chacun connaît qu'est-ce qui
fait l'oeuf
c'est la poule et qui est ce qui fait la
pole c'est moche alors la question est
qui a commencé
ah ah
sf le père de la poule où la poule la
maire de laives ça peut pas être le cas
que les coqs ne pompe pas de quoi qu'ils
aient pas de poule sans eux sans enjeu
les coqs
comme il ya pas de coke sans elle sans
elle les poules
allawi alors oui abbas en elle elle va
sans elle y aurait puni comme des poules
me pousse à aimer ce serait tant mieux
moi j'aurais mangé autant et bien
j'aurais mangé du vos vieux bob encore
bon il a vécu lui même niveau j'avais
déjà vu une petite tête de veau
à la vinaigrette j'aurais mieux fait de
manger un oeuf parce que comme on dit
qui mange un os mangin bof